hi there everyone you don't normally see
me this side of the lens in 60 symbols
videos but today not only are you going
to see my face you're going to see the
inside of my brain
thanks to some technology me worked on
by professor matt brooks and his team
inside the sir peter mansfield imaging
center there before we look at the new
technology though we're going to show
you some older technology should we go
and have a look yep let's do it
here we go
so peter mansfield the late sir peter
mansfield won the nobel prize for his
work on mri there are some great mri
scanners in here
it makes a cool noise if you want to
press the button and pull
nice
this is not an mri this is a meg scanner
matt what is a meg scanner with most
scanners including mri what we usually
look at is brain structure so what what
the brain looks like and that's that's
brilliant if you've got
a tumor or a growth a structural
abnormality but actually in a lot of
disorders um it's not the structure of
the brain that goes wrong it's the
function it's what the networks of
neurons are doing so a meg scanner
measures not brain structure but brain
function so like an mri is like you're
imaging the city and the meg is imaging
all the cars and people exactly that's
exactly what's going on when your
brain's active the neurons the cells
send little electrical currents to one
another those electrical currents make
magnetic fields which pass through our
school and outside our head so our
brains are effectively trying to tell us
a little bit about what they're doing if
we can measure those tiny little
magnetic fields in this helmet there are
275 very very sensitive magnetic field
detectors they measure the distribution
of magnetic fields moment to moment
around your head
so when when when your brain starts
doing something we ask you to do a task
we see these currents flying along
neurons we get changing magnetic fields
and in that way we can infer your brain
activity so if matt very briefly lets me
sit in here
we will show you one of the downfalls of
the meg scanner which will lead us to
what matt himself has been working on
there we go how's that that's not a bad
fit i've actually got a really big head
i struggle with hats normally but i am
getting in or out okay this is the
world's worst adrenaline ride
so you slowly go up oh yeah okay
this feels like you could like a james
bond torture device
all right how's that can you feel the
top of your head yes the
the scan is now hitting the top of my
head yeah okay do you want to come down
a little bit no
it's comfortable so the problem with
conventional mag
is
um we would scan you for 20 minutes
maybe half an hour maybe even longer
um but you can't move your head more
than five millimeters second problem you
mentioned you've got quite quite a big
head so your head is probably filling
that helmet okay
so that means that's really good because
it means your brain is as bad as close
to the sensors which are behind the
plastic as you can get
but if you were going to scan like a a
one-year-old or two-year-old or a baby
their heads are much smaller so their
brains are much further away from the
sensors so the system is effectively one
size fits all we're scanning you but
we'd have to use the same system to scan
a baby and we just can't pick up enough
enough signal to actually measure
anything useful in kids and also matt
typically when someone's being scanned
with one of these meg scanners
do the people's
do you want the person to be doing
something like writing exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so
so remember it's measuring brain
function so we need to evoke brain
function if your
standing sitting really still there's a
limited amount we can get you to do you
know for instance you can't go for a
walk you can't
behave naturally you can't do
handwriting because you need to move
your head to be able to do that kind of
thing so the technology is massively
restrictive
on the tasks that we can get you to do
and therefore you know it's very
restrictive on the brain function that
we can avoid these limitations of meg is
what you're all about and what we're
going to go and ever look at exactly
yeah all right well let's go upstairs
and have a look at what you've been
doing okay let me get you out
[Music]
all right so now we've come into matt's
lab i'm very excited about what's behind
this door and having my brain scanned
but before we do that
matt can you show us some of the stuff
you've got here in this room and tell us
what you've been trying to achieve and
how you've been trying to do it yeah so
um
the system that we just looked at the
really big system um the problem with
that
is to detect the tiny little magnetic
fields that are coming from your brain
the sensors need to be cooled to liquid
helium temperatures so four degrees
kelvin what we've been doing here is
using new types of sensor that's an
optically pump magnetometer or an opm
and that measures the same fields as the
superconducting sensors with the same
sensitivity but it doesn't require the
liquid helium so we can just put one of
those on your head the cool things about
that is because we just put it on your
head your head can move and the sensor
moves with your head so you can move
during a scan and
it doesn't really matter the other thing
we can do is we can just mount them in a
helmet so you can see behind you here
some of the original helmets so that
that was the first one we had where we
were only scanning part of the brain and
the sensors were a lot bigger and then
we went to try and do whole brain and
then we moved to these smaller like lego
brick size sensors this is the sort of
helmet that we're using at the minute so
you'd fill all these holes with these
opms yeah that's right how well can you
explain to me how an opm works how does
it detect these tiny magnetic
fluctuations inside here there's a small
glass cell
which had a bunch of rubidium atoms in
it now those atoms have spin so they
behave like tiny little magnets when we
talk to those atoms with a laser what
that does is it takes all of those
little magnetic moments all those little
magnets and it makes them point in the
same direction so that means the atoms
the atomic gas becomes magnetic then
when it sees an external magnetic field
like we put this on my head and it sees
the field from my brain all of those
aligned atomic magnetic moments suddenly
start deflecting just like a compass
deflects to point north in the earth's
magnetic field and by looking at the
amount of laser light that actually gets
through these atoms we can tell how much
they're deflecting and then we can
measure how big the magnetic field is
from my brain
ah
that is a big door why do you need such
a big door
so this is magnetic shielding right so
um
again it comes down to the fact that the
magnetic fields from your brain are tiny
the fields all around us from cars
moving around to you know cameras to
computers are much bigger than the
fields that we're trying to detect so we
need to screen them out and that's why
there's all this magnetic screening okay
we're in the room now i can see no
no liquid helium device in here
what is in here tell me about some of
the things around us one of the problems
is everywhere around us is the earth's
magnetic field even in this big shielded
room there's still a remnant earth's
magnetic field a tiny magnetic field but
it's still too big that if you move your
head
um
in that field we will be able to see it
on the sensors and it might stop the
sensors working i think you're
underestimating the power of my brain
here
so these are electromagnetic coils and
these things here are detectors so what
we do is we detect that remnant earth's
magnetic field with this reference array
and then we feed back to the coils
so that the coils cancel that magnetic
field to zero so the earth's magnetic
field is in here but this is kind of
like
creating a negative earth magnetic field
exactly yeah yeah yeah and then you add
the two together and it cancels out to
zero and this is where you're going to
have this is where you're gonna be
sitting yeah this is very familiar to
what you showed me before but now we can
see all these opm's it's filled with
opm's i didn't think of it at the time
but of course all these opms have to be
connected by cables that's right yeah
yeah yeah cable management is something
that we're working on okay so the
experiment we're going to be doing today
um you're going to be handwriting so
you're going to be moving your hand in a
specific very well practiced way so the
parts of your brain that we're focusing
on is called the motor cortex your right
hand is controlled by the left side your
left hand is controlled by the right
side okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to make you right with your
right hand then we're going to make you
right with your left hand and we're
going to we're going to look at the
differences between the two so we just
put this on your head
okay yep how's that feel good okay yep
just tuck my ears in yeah and then this
reference array comes now behind you
this reference array is going to measure
the background magnetic field
and that will then feed back to these
coils to put his head in a zero field
environment
in which we can then measure the tiny
magnetic fields from his brain all right
and you need a pencil i need a pencil
thank you we're going to do two
experiments it should be about five
minutes long
in the first experiment
um we want you to just
see the words and write them down okay
so all you've got to do is to write that
word so it's going to happen 30 times
write each word and each time all you've
got to do is write write the words and
then and then we do the fun one yeah
where you've got to do it again but um
with your left hand
good luck
thank you
okay we're ready to start are you are
you happy
yes sir
okay we'll start now
so
over here on the right hand screen
we've got the um opm control each line
is a different sensor on his head and
that's controlling each of those sensors
and then what we're looking at here each
little trace is the magnetic fields that
are being generated by his brain as he
undertakes a task
okay that's all done so we'll just reset
up to to go again with your left hand
this time
okay
okay are you ready to start
yes brilliant okay starting now
so he's kind of looking down to write
the word here and then back up as he's
finished is he left-handed now he's not
only there i should make things more
hard
it's quite hard with your left hand
isn't it very
so how was it
do you know what quite warm it's a yes
it's a bit like having an electric
blanket on your head on about one and a
half so what happens is that each opm
has to be slightly heated to um put the
atoms into a specific regime called the
spin exchange relaxation free regime
this
movement of the um of the atomic
magnetic moments that we see
when when your brain stops firing when
we see those magnetic fields that we
can't measure it unless they're heated
yeah there's 44 lasers on my head yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all right so do you want to come and see
your brain yes i do i do your brain
function it was really interesting when
i was doing it right-handed because it's
quite an easy task i got quite bored
yeah yeah and my mind started wondering
and then i was thinking oh no is my
wandering mind going to ruin the test
admittedly when it was left-handed i
mean
look at look at my right hand look at my
right hand versus my left hand
so when i was left-handed it was pretty
intensive but then i started like
second-guessing you because there were
words like peace and knife and blood and
i thought oh are they testing my
reactions to like emotive words and i'd
started thinking is this some double
test that he's doing and no no all we
were doing there was literally the
mechanics of moving your hand and we're
trying trying to look at the
the motor system and how that works but
you could imagine there's lots more bits
of your brain that are firing other than
your motor system so like your language
cortex so each of those is a word so you
will have reacted to each word in in a
different way but what happens if this
if we say gave you words and then
non-words so just a random collection of
letters so in a word it evokes something
where whereas in a random collection of
letters you just write it down so that's
where we're going with this but but
right now it really is a test of the
scanner more than your brain so does the
scanner work rather than what what are
you thinking so what we're really
looking at is that big blue bit there so
they're called neural oscillations so
your electrical brain activity is
dominated by rhythms so there's a really
famous one called the alpha rhythm what
we're looking at is a slightly higher
frequency one called the beta rhythm so
what happens is when your brain's not
doing anything it's like
idling almost like a car just ticking
over all of the bits of your of your
motor cortex all of the bits that are in
your motor network are just talking to
each other they're just saying hey i'm
still here blah blah blah
and so you get these oscillations but
then all of a sudden when you do your
handwriting task that region of your
brain you you'll say well i need you to
go and actually
do this motor output so it's a
so that's that region certainly drops
out of the network
and so these oscillations these beta
oscillations that maintain this network
suddenly switch off as that region goes
and does its thing and allows you to
remove your hand so so we're looking at
those beta oscillations switch off to
allow your hand to move so in some ways
you're looking at what's not happening
as much as what is happening exactly
yeah so this is your head from the front
and this is when you're using your right
hand this is the part of your brain that
was lighting up now it's not precise
because what we're doing is mapping this
to a template brain not your actual
brain so it's not
absolutely precise but you can see
there's a big chunk of your brain that's
firing that's the part of your brain
that's controlling your right hand when
you're writing these are all the sensors
around the outside so that's where the
sensors were and then this is the brain
and the part of the brain that was
firing up so these are the currents in
your brain that were generating those
magnetic fields that were being picked
up by the sensors was this part of my
brain really that dormant or it was to
the task yeah so if you think about it
you know you're just moving your hand it
doesn't take your whole brain to
to write a word but when i was in there
i was also thinking like oh is james
filming this and what are they talking
about and how is this video going to
work and i would have thought all the
parts of my brain were going crazy they
would have been but if you think about
it we got you to write 30 words you were
writing and then you weren't writing
writing and then we averaged over those
30 things so this is an average of me
over the 30 words exactly it's not just
one a snapshot of one that's right yeah
okay right what you kind of think is
okay when he was writing with his left
hand it's going to be
the opposite side
um
left left brain controls right hand and
right brain controls left hand actually
that's not what's going on so this is
what was going on when you were using
your left hand and this is pretty
typical so you think okay it's just
going to be this bit around here but
actually it's not it's both sides this
is effectively your motor networks and i
really don't like doing this no my
handwriting shows that so so that side
is still like the way most of the action
is happening that one's quite a bit less
yeah yeah yeah so here's when here's
when you did it matt so the difference
between mine and yours is i already had
an underlying mri scan okay so what we
can do is we can then superimpose all of
this activity remember we're measuring
the function but we can superimpose that
over the structure so that this red blob
here was when i was writing with my
right hand so you can see exactly the
same as you it's on the left hand side
of my brain and so that's right-handed
handwriting and then the blue blobs that
we can see are when i was writing with
my left hand and you see exactly the
same as in you
you get this bilateral response you
think it should just be a big blue blob
over here but actually that's not what
goes on because
it's really hard to write with you with
your left hand
what's the future for this technology
why is this important why should i be
excited about it in the very short term
so this is where we do all the physics
so this is our development lab but we
have a mirror image of this system at um
at a place called young epilepsy which
is um affiliated with great ormond
street hospital it's where lots of
children with really really severe
epilepsy go in the same way that we
tracked the area of your brain that was
controlling your hand we can find the
areas of the brain that are associated
with with epileptic seizures and that's
really useful information for
neurosurgeons you can bring a child into
it into a room like this you put the
helmet on you you scan them for 20
minutes they go off and they go for
a cup of tea or whatever and then they
they come back again you can scan them
for 20 minutes again all you got to do
is to keep putting the helmet on and
taking it off again in perhaps the
medium term uh you've probably seen all
of the the headlines about concussion in
sport and things like that and the
military it's a big problem in the
military
um
so when we use this system in people who
have had a concussion
um
we tend to see elevated very low
frequency
activity and that's a proposed biomarker
of concussion which just doesn't exist
at the minute so again that that's
that's another
i feel like clinical angle and then we
can take it further we talk about mental
health depression i think really severe
mental health problems like
schizophrenia and so there are
biomarkers of that so actually the thing
that we're going to be looking at in
your brain or the thing that we've
measured in your brain is we know he's
abnormally in schizophrenia so um so we
can start to get biomarkers of these
really
until now poorly understood and poorly
characterizable mental health conditions
what we are doing a lot of work on is is
making these rooms lighter and much
easier to install and cheaper as well
one final question
yeah
why is it purple
different colors for different size
heads
so this is the biggest helmet we have
okay there's another one over there
which is bright blue and that's for
two-year-olds we didn't want something
that would look clinical we wanted
something that a child might actually
like to wear and kids like bright colors
so so that that's why we went for the
bright color so i'm not quite sure why
it was purple for adults and blue for
two-year-olds and
i think there's an orange one but um but
yeah
there you go
the charge is moving so this is a very
hand waving hand waving description
of what's going on but a moving charge
corresponds to an electric current the
noise is very loud
but it's it stops very suddenly